there are some attempts being made to
pull me into some really childish
YouTube drama I don't even want to go
through it all with you because it's so
dumb and I don't even fully understand
it since I'm kind of busy producing a
show every weekday and I have limited
time to go through really long Twitter
threads but basically over the weekend a
youtuber had a debate that included
white nationalists Richard Spencer and
Karl Benjamin a youtuber who goes by the
name sargon of akkad and some others I
don't even know who write the debate I
think was like 3 or 4 hours long it was
on the channel of a guy named Andrew
wart ski or wash wash ski wore ski and I
somehow got tagged in two tweets about
the debate even though I wasn't in the
debate I don't know why I was initially
tagged into it
but I recognized that name Andrew wore
ski and I checked my GMAT my email
archives and I was actually a few months
ago offered $1500 to debate him on the
Internet and I posted a tweet about that
I just said oh that's interesting I was
actually invited to be on a livestream
Vivat debate with Andrew war ski and
Ivar ski and was offered $1500 to do it
it felt so sketchy in other words I
didn't necessarily believe I'd get paid
that I said sure money upfront and never
heard back I wonder if Richard Spencer
Sargon or others on that abortion of a
debate were offered the same it was
completely true right I was offered the
$1,500 I found the debate to be an
abortion because it was just completely
uncontrolled and people talking over
each other and I don't know that
anything absolutely was was learned and
people went nuts
this Andrea Andrew wore ski guy did a
video filled with ad homonyms about me
there's a youtuber named something like
sticks in my hammer sticks and by hammer
something like that he did a video
making fun of my physical appearance
which is weird since he's got a peculiar
look himself but because that's not
really an argument right like attacking
my physical appearance is not an
argument and my tweet feed just filled
with drama from tons of people I don't
even know and I've had to start just
buting people by the dozens to clear out
my twitter twitter feed so anyway i have
a decision to make here i think it's all
total nonsense i don't care about these
people their argue
about arguing and doing nothing
productive in terms of debating actual
ideas but I know Pat that if I chose to
get involved in this drama that I could
get a lot of attention for the show
right that's saying all publicity is
good publicity if I just started
responding to every one of these people
really aggressively it would grant get a
lot of attention but is it worth it
right like I can only spend so much time
in one day doing all the things related
to the show that I could do social media
being one of them I get how clickbait
media works right it's much easier for
me to just argue with people about
nothing online than to well research a
story for the show but I don't think
that our core audience why there are
only so many hours in the day they're
only only switch time in the show for
you and I think it has to do with one of
those things where you don't really want
to punch down too much I mean there are
people who make entire video series and
channels and playlists dedicated
entirely to just hating the David Pakman
right there's a it's a cottage industry
that has developed around just making
videos quote debunking our clips anyway
let me know your thoughts for now I'm
just muting these people I I and and
going along with my day but if you think
it would be interesting to see me see me
start mixing it up on Twitter let me
know but my instinct is most people in
the audience would rather us talk about
politics and analyze issues and ideas